Donn's how is the movie going so far
well when you take a look at what the
roubles done since Putin has started to
speak about an hour and a half ago it
looks like a heartbeat monitor it goes
up it goes down it goes up it down this
is your remarkable comments at one
moment mr. Putin suggests that the
central bank is independent that the
next he doesn't approve of what they're
doing we've gotten a lot of mixed
messages but on one crucial point and
that is he's been consistent the West is
to blame and he's got a precise figure
for you Brendon 25 to 35 percent of the
economic crisis is because of Western
Shanks so that's not 37 that's that's 35
we know exactly right right I mean it's
it's that's Russian precision on that
very point I mean even metaphorically
his language his language is remarkable
he is talking about a bear about Russia
being a bear that likes to have honey
and and and varies but the West wants to
defang this bear and there would be
nothing but a stuffed animal remarkable
retic rhetoric out of Vladimir Putin and
he's telling the bear to hibernate I
should point out we're looking at this
press conferences live these can go on
for as long as four hours but I thought
what was interesting is he's sending a
signal this could last for two years
that means the Russians are going to
expect privation for a while two years
is what he put out there and he did he
did we should mention he did give
himself some room on that right he did
say if you know if things aren't working
out after two years maybe we'll have to
reevaluate and maybe cut some programs
so even prepared the public for
additional economic pain but on the
crucial issue of Ukraine he said one
lonely he's sparred with the Ukrainian
journalist Vladimir Putin hasn't given
anything the only hope for optimism is
that he and Merkel had as we mentioned
yesterday had that wait call on Monday
evening along with Poland and others
it's really the only hope but really not
a lot of optimism coming out of today
not a lot of optimism and I'm glad you
brought up Merkel here because Putin
with a near-record approval ratings I
think somewhere in the 85 percent range
Merkel of course also very popular in
her Germany as well how much of her
popularity is hinged on her relationship
with Putin does she have sway with
himself
oh very little her population popularity
has to do is sort of what they used to
call us too
politic the view towards the east it's
more on the economy and what Mangla
Merkel has done and somewhat internally
given credit for saving the euro now
whether or not the Euro crumbles we've
got some concern in Greece what happens
next but most of Merkel's approval
rating really is based on economics let
it's less focused on Russia there seems
to be a consensus on Russia and that is
you know sanctions need to have some
teeth she repeated that this morning and
that sanctions need to stay in place
until Crimea or until the sovereignty of
Ukraine is respected Hans there's an EU
summit today or the leaders they're more
worried about what's going on in Moscow
or what's going on in Athens technically
- the summit - in the next couple days
is gonna be more Russia focused you know
Athens got about a two month lease on
life so we'll have to see how these
presidential votes look in Athens
today's didn't go great excuse me
yesterday's didn't go well that was
expected not to go well the real boy you
know heartbreak moment for for Athens
and for Greece's is December 29 on
whether or not we'll have snap elections
so right now it's a wait-and-see
approach on Greece I put that more in
that basket